We're now gonna take a look at creating groom materials as there are a few things
We need to make sure that we do in order to have the best looking grooms possible now with
The standard material editor we can create all types of different looking grooms and here's an example of that
We've got a red one and a brown one
We can create purple and green and all types of great looking grooms
Now when we are creating material
There are a few things that we need to have enabled to make sure that it renders correctly first off
Our shading model is going to need to be set to hair
We're also going to want to enable the two-sided option to ensure that we can see the groom from every angle
If you are experiencing some issues make sure that under the usage used with hair strands is enabled
This is needed in order for the material to render correctly
Now this should be set automatically when the shading model is set to hair. However, just make sure that it was
Enabled here if you're having some issues now inside of the material you can make them material
That's just simply a color plug right into the base color or there is the hair
Attributes material node this allows you to access various attributes from your hair in this case in this material
We're accessing the you and the seed the seed is a random value here and the you is the longer
Strands inside of our groom and we are using those
To color our hair in different ways now inside of unreal
Let's take a look at how we can do this. The first thing is we're gonna right-click and go material
I'm gonna call this
Mat underscore hair and then double click on it to open it up now again
we do want to make sure that we have our
Shading model here set to hair and that we enable two-sided and
I'm also going to look up the hair
attributes here, so
What with this node what we're gonna do here is I'm gonna right-click and look for a vector
We're gonna look for a vector parameter here
vector and then
Let's see vector
Where is the vector parameter, there we go
I'm gonna just call this hair and we're gonna give it a default value of
Like a no some color like that. Alright, so what we're gonna do with this here, we're gonna hold down the M key
we're gonna multiply the you value here by this and what that's gonna do is
It's gonna give us a little bit of variation here in our hair
So I'm just gonna move this over real quick and we're gonna double click on our hair here
Which is opened up. I'm just gonna pull it over so we can see this and then right here in our element is zero
We are gonna make sure that we have our hair selected and we're gonna put that right there
That is gonna change our hair
So again, we can see here that we by using this you and I'll bring this back on screen here by using this you
We're getting some values here. And if I was to change this to the V
Click apply here, you'll see that we'll get the opposite of that. So there we go. So we're getting
Some of those other values and then you can see here the tips. We're getting a white value
so again, the purpose of the hair attributes node is to allow us some ability to
Adjust various parameters or attributes set to the hair so that we can get more variety
When we're using it on one of the other ones I like to use here is seed if I was to do
That here we can see kind of like some more more random bits for the hair. We need some more random colors
So again, there's a lot of really interesting things that we can do with our hair using the hair
material attributes node or just by simply plugging in
Options to the base color and the roughness inside of our material